ah well alright then hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome did they
come at poop time no don't click away
this game is for real if you guys were
watching the double feature of horror
that I did a with a little bit ago this
may look like a giant pile of [ __ ] but
beneath that [ __ ] is a nugget I'm not
really selling this very well am i okay
all of my bad description of this game
aside we're gonna go into the forest
because I'm not going for completionist
round here and I've already done the
home one and I want to go into the
forest to give it a little bit of serves
of skier there's three enemies one above
you and a tree tore out in the woods who
tried to take a poop they won't let you
let's get to this oh hi I didn't read
the instructions I don't know how to
beat you can you just leave me to my poo
and go so who else is here oh boy oh oh
what why
hey don't come any closer
try and trying to poop here just try to
try to do my that what do you I don't
know what to do about you what it's a
it's a game of red light green light up
here and it's a game of yes poo no poo
over here what are you don't stop how do
I stop you okay
well that's really doing it for me oh hi
what the far
ah hey what I don't know what to do
about this situation oh this seems bad
well alright then I'm now constipated oh
that's but this game is surprisingly
it's surprisingly good ok you know what
I'm gonna go back to the menu and I
might actually read what I need to do ok
tree enemy is always crawling down
towards you make it crawl back up by
looking at him with the flashlight
zombies will frequently spawn they will
slowly be walking OH
pick a rock up from the rock I need to
do what chica does and she Sprint's
before she takes a poo okay so scarecrow
it'll appear I'll see him in a tree and
when he disappears from the tree I turn
the flashlight off this seems difficult
alright but let's do this okay so
looking up at you where's my rock pile
all right there's my rock pile I got a
rock I throw it at you didn't do nothin
but you gonna take that away with you
and you oh oh man the mechanics of this
would have fun okay where's ombo oh well
sorry about the terrible throw there
I'll just wait till you get closer I
guess oh boy I'm gonna foam maybe I
maybe I did get it yeah oh that didn't
get you at all oh no my rock
oh my ancestors are gonna be alright I
don't see the Scarecrow anywhere but I
apparently am NOT I'm not nailing these
zombo's these bozos oh hey you're real
close to me oh sorry
terrible throws I know oh god that's not
okay well there's a scarecrow oh that's
not good I'm gonna die one way or
another here it looks like it's gonna be
through that scarecrow okay I see you
there
[ __ ] okay quick I think
I don't like that damn it
now Koch to Putin alright so the trick
is load up with a rock and just wait
looking at the guy to get him up as much
as possible because that's gonna be like
the determining factor alright you you
get back up in that tree don't think
that you can give me a spook don't wanna
spook maybe I can go by noise if they
hear if they're nice to be alright no
one's there yeah you get oh you get up
in that tree how far away can you go up
in that tree let's find out let's go for
an adventure yeah that's right oh oh man
must be hard on your thighs to crawl
backwards like that but I don't care
good hey get out of here okay I already
have a rock idiot okay this is dicey
this is legitimately dicey like I gotta
admit they in the dark okay I think I'm
safe I don't know what safe means in
this poop nightmare Oh God hey don't do
that
I know I have a rock I want to throw it
at the guy alright we're good
alright oh I can do this I can poop for
realsies I'm gonna be able to poop in
the woods
I don't even think this is a twin I
think I think I'm just doing a wall
squat by by a goddamn tree here there's
there is no toilet I'm trying to take a
[ __ ] at the base of this tree oh boy
this is not ideal for me did I poop was
that me pooping
it was that successful poop nope I got
200 seconds left I don't like this I
don't know where to look okay scarecrows
still there no point looking up so I'm
as well good stuff
okay maybe like the darkness is the
perfect opportunity II okay all right
I'm assume he's gone I don't know when
the gone this happens
oh just like I don't know when the gone
this happens in my boy that means
talking about pooping act God my
commentary really turns to [ __ ] when I'm
in this game even worse now I think the
the stick breaking is them is him going
away I have no idea what he's terrifying
100 seconds of poop left maybe this is
just one big poop it's just taking me a
long I like also they don't kill me they
just like they interrupt my pooping
process therefore I can't poop and
that's literally the only punishment
here all right
no no no okay I got this yes yes yes and
no also no yes and also no yes and also
no rocks get rocked
am I good okay I think I'm good okay
get rocked all right I think I'm gonna
win this yes 30 seconds of poop give me
that sweet finish I don't think I
brought any toilet paper I think in
trouble that's right you don't want to
be near something about to happen you
better crawl back then up in that tree
what about what about me poop and
drawers all these monsters out of the
woods
huh what kind of curse is this what kind
of horrible demon cursed me to have poop
demons come after me in the monstrous
dark and also why am I in the tree you
know I wouldn't put it past me in this
weird world that I live in anyway that
is they come at boot time I I don't
think I'm gonna do it completion it's
still business but goddamn is that funny
all right so anyway thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know what
you thought they'd come at poop time I'm
gonna put a link to the game down in the
description are the comments the
description below and then you can play
for yourself for all the other levels so
thanks him but if you want sure as
always see you
[Music]